so there is a serious problem going on
within our scientific community
take for example good unpaid on located
in Indonesia the world's oldest pyramid
that almost nobody has ever heard of in
fact it dates back more than 25,000
years and there is still a chamber 50
feet down that has not been excavated
and one can only imagine why more than
thirty four professional scientists have
literally campaigned to prevent this
site from being excavated and you want
to know why to protect their own grant
funding because grant funding equals a
paycheck you know guys just like
politics the government the news media
we've all seen in the last few years
just how corrupt things truly are and
how money focused our world society has
become and unfortunately it has made its
way into the mainstream scientific
community in fact this happened a very
long time ago just that most people
weren't aware of it now let me share
with you a little bit of information
about this site get on Padang it's also
just known as a megalithic site it's not
a traditional pyramid like you'll find
in Egypt or Mesoamerica it was carved
out of a mountain in fact you can see
some of these illustrations here to give
you a feel for what they believe it
looks like and it utilizes natural stone
blocks basalt volcanic rock that is
essentially hexagonal shape I mean this
is the same phenomena that we've seen
elsewhere in the world you may be
familiar with what's called Giant's
Causeway in Ireland that many people
thought was a megalithic site but after
listening to dr. Robert Schoch explained
this I mean we've seen this elsewhere
throughout the world numerous sites and
it's just a natural phenomena and the
people that live there or that built
this megalithic site and I can show you
more details in just a second utilize
these stones but speaking of dr. Robert
Schoch who got his master's and PhD in
geology from Yale or dr. Danny Hillman
who got his doctorate in geology from
Caltech guys these people have visited
the site conducted excavations they've
proven that this site is incredible that
it's not natural in itself it is
literally a megalithic site that has
been built upon itself over tens of
thousands of years because through
evidence obtained through two different
core samples
which identified at least seven items
that dated back more than 25,000 years
am I the only one that's just completely
disturbed about the fact that 50 feet
down there's some sort of chamber
possibly carved out of a lava flow but
there's a large structure that's
artificial something man-made 50 feet
down never been seen before we don't
know what's in it and that there's been
almost three dozen scientists that have
tried to stop us from finding out I mean
that is freaking disturbing now as you
look at these photographs here it's easy
to understand that some people may have
thought as they did that it was just a
natural sight and it wasn't man-made
whatsoever
of course the drill samples proved that
the deeper they go the older it gets and
it goes back at least 5,000 years well
at the surface and it goes down to
twelve thousand five hundred years
twenty thousand twenty two thousand
years to twenty five thousand years
again the deeper they go the older it
gets now to kind of give you a picture
what this may have looked like if you go
to nearby Pompeii you might seem nearby
it's actually a few thousand miles away
I guess it's in the same region but it's
an island it's pretty incredible but
when you look at these stone walls here
same exact thing these volcanic rocks
same shape and they stacked up on each
other
and that's what we're looking at here
over at gunung padang and it's also
worth mentioning that if you go halfway
across the world to Machu Picchu in
South America you find these level
terraces of stone walls and it's the
same thing that they're finding or at
least similarities of to that of GaN
gunung padang but of course the big
mystery is about this underground
chamber 15 meters down about 50 feet
they've identified it through like I
said to accord drill samples as well as
ground-penetrating radar you know like
you've seen from Jurassic Park and this
technology has developed significantly
and they use it in so many different
ways throughout the world whether it's
an industry whether it's just doing
maintenance and utilities and it's helps
archaeologists find dinosaur bones it's
helped civil engineers fix city problems
in so many other things and since I'm
discussing ground-penetrating radar as
well as corruption within the scientific
community I have to discuss dr. Zahi
Hawass who was the minister of
Antiquities for Egypt a government
position a politician assigned by the
president of Egypt this guy I have to
tell you because I have received so many
comments about him on all my videos
about ancient Egypt that this guy is a
total liar he's a total fraud and I know
that that sounds kind of extreme but you
know I've heard
many other people say it and upon doing
research on my own oh my god and I have
to bring it up because this guy is
considered by many and by himself
included the world's most famous
archaeologist
he's also been referred to as the
Pharaoh himself this guy has given tours
throughout Egypt to leaders throughout
the world he's written books he's made a
ton of money and he has also denied
numerous examples of the most recent
scientific data that has presented
itself or presented the scientific
community such as the true age of the
Sphinx in fact I highly recommend and
I'll include a link to where you watch a
debate between him and Graham Hancock
where he completely denies the use of
ground-penetrating radar
he's denied the age of the Sphinx and
refused to even discuss it he's denied
gobekli tepe
which is dated at eleven thousand six
hundred years ago you've heard me talk
about it in this guy the way he's
responded to any new information has
been extreme I mean this guy has walked
out on people he's been incredibly
disrespectful he's include people of
being liars and thieves which is a
really interesting thing for him to say
because if you're not aware he was
accused of stealing artifacts from the
Great Pyramid itself he denied it
he lied his way out of it there's a lot
of information there a few people went
to jail over it
they say that he was the reason why they
were able to do it he got away with it
guys and this was all after the fact
that he had got fired from his position
itself so I guess that's good news all
the way around and let me just say
because this is actually a negative
message let me say something good about
him on live TV he acknowledged that the
100 ton stone boxes located the sear
p.m. I've mentioned this in multiple
videos which are a complete mystery he
himself has acknowledged that they have
no idea how they did this he's no idea
how they fit them into the nukes which
at least one example of it it's
impossible to move it in and out of the
nook itself and the fact that they were
machined down to within a level of
accuracy of to ten thousandths of an
inch and yes that is an example of lost
ancient high technology of some kind but
I'll leave it at that
but I digress and going back to Graham
Hancock and ganang Padang I would never
even have heard of this site if it
wasn't for the Joe Rogan podcast with
Graham Hancock really discuss it and
where it stands now is that they're
supposed to start excavations back up it
had been delayed by a couple years for
what I understand and because of all the
political drama and once Indonesia got a
new president he was presented the
information the oven
said yeah let's get this going again in
fact they're gonna increase tours that
can have a whole train system set up so
the country can have people see the site
more often and again they're gonna
continue their excavations I'm waiting
on more information and this site being
at least 12,500 according to the
mainstream even though there's enough
data that they use to show that it's
more than twenty five thousand years old
they at least acknowledge that it's one
of the oldest sites on earth and the
fact that most people haven't even heard
of it and again you know you could look
at this thing like well I'm not sure how
impressive it it is but guys there's a
chamber 50 feet down and who knows
what's in it we're talking going back to
the beginning of the last ice age at 26
thousand years ago so this site is
unbelievably interesting dr. Robert
Schoch who I highly recommend you look
into he discusses it in detail and all
the overwhelming evidence of that this
isn't natural that this you can see and
he outlines it in great detail of all
the evidence that this was a very
sophisticated site and what you're
looking at here is something that has
deteriorated over tens of thousands of
years anyways guys I'll keep you posted
when more information comes to light
about this I highly recommend you check
out Graham Hancock comm as he's been
giving updates about this but it's been
a little while so hopefully some new
information will be coming around soon
and I'll be making a full fledged video
at some point in the future outlining
all the examples that show that the
mainstream scientific community is
literally ignoring the most recent data
guys this is not what's supposed to be
happening we're seeing that people with
egos people that don't want to be wrong
people that want to protect their
paychecks they are running the show and
the implications of the fact that the
true history of ancient human
civilization is far older and was far
more advanced and we're ever taught in
school the implications are significant
because whatever happened to that
civilization that made it just get wiped
out will eventually happen again and if
when you control the past you control
the present in the future as well and we
need to learn from the past in that
minimum it's incredibly interesting so
I'll leave it at that leave me a comment
let me know what your thoughts are but
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight and I
got many more videos to come and a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody